hey what's up my name is Samuel leaves
and in this video I want to talk to you
about what I believe
to be the best property investment
opportunity right now in 2023 no one's
doing this even though it's a buyer's
market what does a buyer's market mean
it means that there's more houses on the
market than there are buyers which means
that you can get a bargain property
which means it's a buyer's market so if
you're not buying right now
in this buyer's market we're gonna do
wait for it to be a seller's market and
pay over the odds I think now is a
golden opportunity if you invest right
and in this video I want to talk to you
about what I think is the best
opportunity which is auction properties
I'm getting some juicy deals from
auctions right now and I wanted to give
you a little crash course in this video
about how to get into the auction
bidding how to get into auction buying
the five things you need to look out for
I've also shaved my head because I am
going to be working with a whole bunch
of people over the next few weeks to
become financially free in property
because I think that the opportunity
when you hear about someone stupid you
can do from auction problems you don't
even have to buy an auction you can
underwrite that means that you can agree
to buy a price but then if it goes over
that price then you just pocket the
difference I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about that in this video so
I'm going to be working with a group of
people over the next few weeks and my
challenge to myself is I shave my head
and I thought if I can if I can help as
many people as possible
become financially free until my hair
grows back how many can that be so I've
shaved my head off as a bit of a social
experimental challenge I'm going to see
how many people I can help become
full-time property investors and become
financially independent in property in
2023 in this opportunity so if you want
to take advantage of that opportunity
we've got limited spaces but I've left a
link in the description
and you can come and spend a full day
with me for one pound where I'm going to
be teaching everything I know about
property into the property investors
crash course so get booked on if it's
the last thing you do get booked on and
make sure if you're watching this
shortly after the video is posted you do
it soon because it will be it will be
sold out real soon so get book one pound
come and spend a day with me later on in
this week and also next week I'm in
London Manchester Birmingham so auctions
I
I was speaking to an estate agent
recently and she said to me she said um
Samuel there's a property
that you might be interested in the only
problem is it's going to auction
and I said I don't know you know auction
you've got the the fact that there's
loads of people there all bidding at
once and you've got all the competition
you've got auction fees you've got the
fact that you've only got 28 days to buy
so like you know in the past like last
year the year before last I wasn't mine
a lot through auction I found some
property but not a lot so I sent to this
day agent I said yeah you know it sounds
interesting but I think I'll pass
I said when's the auction
she said tomorrow
I said okay well you know let me know
how it goes
she rang me back the following day which
was this morning
and told me what she told me that the
property didn't sell at auction
I'm like okay now if a property doesn't
sell at auction
how do you think the seller is feeling
I'll tell you how the seller's feeling
the sun is feeling
very demotivated they're feeling afraid
why do you put your house on auction the
reason you put your house on auction
generally is because you need the money
fast
because you if you sell your house on
auction and someone bids they've got to
buy the house within 28 days and if they
don't you you keep their deposit you
force them you give them 10 days force
them and you can even sue them if they
don't buy it from the diff if you if you
resell it at a lower price you can sell
them for the difference so it's a very
fast way to make illiquid money I.E
money and property that's illiquid
because it's tied up liquid
so people that are selling from auction
are usually people that want their money
fast
if a property doesn't sell at auction
which a lot of properties aren't selling
at auction right now because people are
scared because interest rates are so
high then what happens then what happens
is the smart people like you hopefully
watching this video Boom come in the day
after the auction and buy what we call
Post auction now you don't even have to
Buy Auction terms you don't have to buy
with you know 28 days and the auction
fees you can just buy regular it's
whatever you offer but post auctions are
to wear some of the bangers are because
these people need the money
I need the money fast another one is
pre-auction so let's say you see a house
on and it's on auction and it's just
been listed and next month is the day
when everybody's all going to be bidding
because how auction works is the
property's advertised you'll see it on
usually on Rightmove and zoopla but then
there'll be an auction day and on that
auction day that's the day where
everybody bids it's a bit like bidding
for something on eBay so they're all
being online usually it used to happen a
lot of live but now it's normally on
live but online so everyone bids and
then it's like ticking clock and then
the highest bidder just before the end
of the um of the auction it buys the
property but here's the thing if there's
a property that's in auction next month
okay so I say 200 000 pounds
often the seller especially in today's
market where interest rates are high
house prices have been 4
. it's a buyer's market so the seller's
thinking I sure hope my house sells next
month in auction
it's on for two hundred thousand you
know that actually the value is 250
000. so they've put it on a 200 they
might be hoping for more but they might
be scared that it doesn't sell at all so
you come in and you put forward what we
call a pre-auction offer which is look
I'll buy it
but I'll buy pre-auction for 180. how
does that sound and then they've got the
choice they can either take the 180
which is a little bit of a hit but have
the money now and it doesn't even have
to go to auction or they can say no
you're all right mate but then in their
mind they're worried that they won't
sell it at all when it goes to auction
so that's pre-auction underwriting is
when and this is something that is just
incredible
um
if you enjoyed this video hit like man I
really hope you hit like
um it helps the algorithm share the
video around because this is like real
life property advice real life stuff so
underwriting is when you say I'll buy it
for 180. okay
but we'll let it continue to go to
auction
so I'll buy it for 180
but we'll let it continue to go to
auction
if it doesn't sell like your biggest
fear is and no one bids then I'll buy it
for 180. but if it sells for over 80
anything above 180 we'll split the
difference we'll split the we'll split
what um anything above what I do so in
other words if it sells for one uh 250
then there's a seventy thousand pound
per split so you get 35 000 pounds for
literally nothing just for underwriting
the deal and being there safety blanket
that said you'll buy it for 180 if no
one else does and they'll get 35 Grand
obviously they'll also get the 187 the
property that's underwriting so when you
really understand auction properties and
you understand post auction pre-auction
um how to bid at the auction
underwriting there's some real bangers
because this is where a real motivated
sellers are the most motivated sellers
generally are at auction motivated
sellers are auction combined with these
times and I know a lot of people are
holding out oh I'm just gonna wait until
the property Market picks back up why
why are you going to wait for the
property Market to pick back up because
then right now the Market's going down
and by the way people some people are
freaking out the Market's going down uh
yeah
like it always does because the property
Market goes up and then down and then up
and then down and then up for a few
years and then down for a couple that's
how that's that's the world of Economics
that's how it's always been and always
will be and the thing is when do people
get rich when do people get the best
deals when the Market's going up and it
was all bidding and it's a seller's
market and you ring the estate agent and
the estate agent says join the queue
there's 27 offers
is that when you get rich in real estate
or do you get rich in real estate when
now when everyone's scared when there's
only a few people buying like me and
there's loads of people selling and
that's when you get banging deals and
people say oh but the properties are
going to keep going down more and more
and more okay I remember in uh when I
got started in property in 2008 the
Great Recession okay what happened all
the banks were going bust and then the
market started crashing I was buying in
2009 and everyone was telling me I was
crazy what are you doing and then what
happened a year or two years later 2011
houses bounced back up
and by by but within a five six seven
year period in many parts of the UK
they're doubled in value in London house
prices doubled in value in many parts
from 2012 to 2017.
when was the best time to buy
was it was it 2009 2010 when everyone
was scared of course so you know and
also another thing is this I mean geez
this video is just getting better and
better but I'll say I'll share one but
you've got to catch this this is this is
like an economic prediction right now
based on lenders so
lenders okay let me stop by saying this
the reason that houses are falling is
because interest rates have risen that
that's when oh base rate went from 0.5
percent to now
so now people can't afford to get
mortgages because they can't afford the
interests and they don't pass the stress
tests
so what's happened is because we can't
afford to get a mortgage they're not
able to buy and because people are able
to buy or don't want to buy because of
how high the rates are going to be it's
meaning that house prices are dropping
so the real question is what's going to
happen with interest rates
our interest rates going to go up again
are they going to keep going up or are
they going to come down
well the lenders think they're going to
come down how do I know that I know that
because uh a year and a half two years
ago when interest rates were really low
if you fixed a
um if you if you tied yourself into like
a 10 year fix or a five year fix it was
really expensive but if you just took
out a short-term fix like two year fix
you could fix it really cheap why
because they knew the rates were going
to go up
so now now
if the longer you fix it
the cheaper it is
because they know that rates are going
to go down
just think about that I mean listen this
is just my opinion
um however I'm friends with a lot of
billionaires and I have done hundreds of
property deals and studied economics
over the last 15 years
um but my opinion is I think rates work
I think they've already started to and I
as soon as rates begin to come down
what's going to happen then is house
prices are going to stop going up again
so but listen you look back over the
last thousand years over the last
thousand years you can see house prices
go up down up down but oh on all over
average they go up over time house
prices generally double in value every
10 years
and when people were saying this 15 20
years ago Ah that's not going to happen
the next time it did oh it's not gonna
happen the next step it did so history
tends to repeat itself now it's a
buyer's market make sure if you do buy
from auction though make sure you know
what you're doing make sure you
understand how to you know
what to look for when you view the
property make sure you do view it before
you bid make sure you understand how to
read a legal pack or you understand that
you need to and pay someone's fit for
you uh get a server on the property make
sure that you know the maximum amount
that you're prepared to bid to before
you start bidding because when
intelligence is high sorry when emotions
are high intelligence is low and it's
pretty emotional when you're there
bidding so make sure you know what your
final bit is and make sure you get your
Finance in place I recently settled my
own bank
um Samuel leads finance and the sole
purpose of the company is to give money
out to my students who are buying
properties and we're fast so if you want
Finance training education come come
spend the day with me honestly it will
app spending a full day with me will
absolutely change and revolutionize your
perspective on property investment
business personal development and uh
it'll be an incredible day so I don't
know how much longer I'm gonna be doing
these programs but I'm running one uh
this weekend and next weekend so I'll
leave a link in the description get
booked on let's spend a day together and
I'll see you guys real soon God bless
peace out thank you